good morning John it's Tuesday February
6th clean chin I'm really sorry I didn't
realize that was going to be quite that
horrible
apparently wax is not made for facial
hair I've read now online some really
horrible stories about big chunks of
skin getting ripped off I had no idea
I'm so sorry that looked really horrible
and also extremely funny three tries to
get it the first time that oh well at
least those hairs won't grow back for a
while or maybe ever since you may have
done some permanent damage anyway during
our tour of the entire southeastern
United States
Katherine and I have run across several
babies and I can't help thinking about
your response to the how do you feel
about babies question you want an army
of babies dozens of babies such your
only problem is you don't know where to
put babies that is not my only problem I
have found the babies to be rather
adorable though uncle Hank
I'm uncle Hank I think that's adorable
yeah when I married Katherine I became
an uncle because Katherine's brother has
a son so when you have a baby I want
people to say oh I'm an uncle now cuz
I'm already an uncle sorry about that
anyway now that I've met a few I
actually kind of like them I've met a
very interesting baby here at
Katherine's parents house she's called
baby shingi I want you to listen very
carefully to what baby shinji has to say
play pattycake I'm stinky chicken poo
hey this is the kind of baby I want you
can shake it and make noises it's
scary-looking
I am still very excited about the
prospect of you having a baby though so
don't take the uncle thing the wrong way
I'm especially excited about the
prospect of you having babies because
then mom maybe will stop bothering me
about it so much
so how is that going for you I can think
of a dozen great places to put a baby
inside of your apartment it could be fun
like everyday Sarah comes home and
you'll say find the baby and she has to
search through the entire apartment
trying to find where you hid the baby
Wow having a baby is gonna be a lot of
fun I hope you let me know as soon as
you have any news on that front just
like the time you called me five or six
minutes after you lost your virginity
it's really important that you share
stuff like that with me anyway I hope
both of us are fertile and that neither
of us ever have to be punished again
I'll see you tomorrow